[Music]
the anime mentor what words or
descriptions come to your mind when
hearing that set of words perhaps
someone who serves as a hero's guide and
best friend or maybe the sacrificial
lamb to make some villain look oh so
powerful whatever the case may be we can
all agree on one thing anime mentors are
badass that's why for today's list we're
going through some of my favorite
moments when the anime mentor just shows
off his strength in front of the student
after all one of the easiest ways to get
this upstart kid to trust you is to show
them that you mean business
hunter hunter is one of my all-time
favorite shows and while the first
person most fans would think of when it
comes to mentors is biscuit i feel like
kite's pretty underrated one of the most
cold-hearted mentors in the series kite
showed his mettle when he leads the team
into battle against the kimira ants
running into the hagio division gone and
killua get tested through individual
battles against the enemies for kite
all he needs is his scythe and the
entire division gets wiped out in one
fell swoop
black clovers yami often puts on a show
and episode 49 is his crowning moment
[Music]
mentors i really like yami because he
gives off that rough edge there are
mentors who look badass but yami takes
it a step further and shows how badass
he was with dark cloak dimension slash
it's a power that's so strong that it's
capable of cutting dimensions dwarfing
whatever veto can throw at him there's
no kill the overkill and seeing yami
just put this elf down in such a
dominant fashion is a real thrill
everyone just looks on in amazement at
the power of their captain they're in
good hands as long as xiaomi is around
they know they can have someone to rely
on while they strive to grow stronger
let's continue with the new gin shonen
train with benimaru vs infernal demon
quite the underage moment right here as
shinra and arthur find themselves in
quite the fight against the infernal
demon who else should show up at
benimaru himself to benimaru this fight
is personal with this powerful fight in
front of him he simply flexes his power
while shinra and arthur watch on easily
turning away the demon's attacks
benimaru holds back out of concern for
the town before deciding to take the
battles to the skies here he finally
gets a chance to obliterate the enemy
with his awe-inspiring sun wheel people
have been applauding the sound direction
for this scene and i think that it does
add to the moment so much that bass
alone is one of the most awesome and
satisfying sounds you could hear from
fire force that's the perfect compliment
to watching benimaru nonchalantly take
the enemy down
rayleigh's conqueror's haki deserves a
mention
there's so much that you can do with so
little do you believe that saying you
sure as hell can believe it after seeing
rayleigh's conquerors haki in the
auction house rayleigh contrary to
expectations didn't have the most
explosive entry at first glance but the
sheer mystery of his silhouette entering
the scene more than makes up for it it
even feels quite ominous and all and
when he does finish his entry all he
needed was one conqueror's haki to clean
house there's just that sense of wonder
and i dare say dreading the characters
expressions there's that eerie feeling
of what the hell just happened and it
really kept the fans guessing when it
comes to rayleigh's true strength now
that my friends is how you build hype
with just one very pivotal moment what
an amazing debut for rayleigh
saitama vs genos is a rather unique
application
you see while most mentors show off
their power by fighting villains and
enemies in front of their protege
saitama and genos do it quite
differently instead of enemies feeling
the full brunt of said mentor's power
it's jenos who offers to do it wanting
to see the extent of saitama's power
this is a rather unique setup for a
mentor showing his protege his power but
it works i was a bit worried as to how
the battle would drag on due to
saitama's one-hit ko gimmick and all but
we surprisingly got quite the
entertaining performance that shows
jenos determination this is a battle
that clocks in almost five minutes which
i think also serves as a testament to
jenos's strength it's a friendly spot
with not a lot of high stakes but it
also gives us a taste of what the two
could do to each other
enjoying the video so far i'd like to
encourage you to hit that subscribe
button subscribe ring the bell and be
here the next time i upload more
countdown videos that's enough for now
it's time to get going
again ah it's nice to look now once
again where it all began it's so
refreshing after so many videos focusing
on the final war arc and madara you know
for most of the series we've heard of
how great minato was and all but we've
never actually seen that strength in
action that is until the flashback arc
which shows us important groundwork on
how the nine tails in naruto came to be
toby at this point of the timeline was
one of the most powerful characters
around and it showed in the battle with
all of his power even minato struggled
to land a hit but with some ingenious
tactics and possibly the most epic rasan
gan in the series so far the fourth
hokage defies all odds and finally
forces toby to escape coolest mentor and
call his dad you get both in monato not
to mention being super smart too who
else can devise a counter to the very
overpowered kamui on the fly
[Applause]
may have been one of the best highlights
of early my hero academia
what a way to close out the first part
of my hero academia there's no bigger
test for our heroes than an outright
battle of survival against some of the
toughest villains there is and it seems
like our heroes are in for certain doom
until all might arrive in a way this is
pretty much just a punch harder fight
however one can't overlook the emotions
the scene evoked when put together the
build up to the actual fight together
make a great moment from almight's
appearance as a beacon of hope and how
he just casually talks down and beats
down the nomu it's just so satisfying
this is a scene that never gets old i
personally think that all might have
some scenes down the line that one up
this in terms of awesomeness but it's
here where we first get a glimpse of how
far ahead the world's symbol of peace is
he's pretty much deus ex machina
incarnate around this time and his save
remains one of my favorites from shonen
anime
after all of that we take a look at
tengen versus [ __ ]
[Music]
one of the biggest moments of demon
slayers red light district r gives us
the upper moon [ __ ] taking on the
kamado siblings yep you heard that right
nozuko finally gets a chance to shine as
she engages in combat against one of the
most powerful demons that the series has
shown so far and it's a fight that took
everything from them even with nezuko's
awakened powers the siblings still had
their hands before dealing with [ __ ] in
an epic battle that could have gone
either way the garmado has come out on
top but not before sustaining major
injuries the bad news naki's still ready
to go for more the good news it opens
for tengen to come in and finish the job
i almost felt like adding this moment
was cheating because tengen just came in
for the last hit but considering that
the siblings at full strength are unable
to completely eliminate [ __ ] it just
shows the difference in power between
them and a pillar 10 games boast
afterwards it's pretty cool too that's
way too easy isn't it
suspiciously so these guys they're gonna
be in for a real surprise
and to wrap up today's list we have gojo
versus jogo
when i first saw gojo i knew we're in
for something special he has that whole
laid back and cool attitude along with
the accolades to go with it he made one
hell of a first impression in the very
first episode and i knew that it was
only a matter of time before he'd break
out as one of the anime community's
favorite mentor figures and that he did
when he and yuji encountered jogo joko
quickly goes on the attack and seemingly
finishes gojo off in one hit however the
badass teacher brushes it off like
nothing and proceeds to do the same
thing to the next attacks that the curse
can throw at him when eugene he got
caught in the domain expansion it didn't
even faze gojo one bit in what looked to
be a very dangerous and deadly fight
gojo casually breezes through it flexing
and turning this whole affair into a
freaking tutorial session where he can
teach yuji more about domain battles
there wouldn't be a bigger mentor flex
than that
that's gonna do it for my top moments of
mentors showing off their power to their
students i'd love to know your favorite
among them and i'm curious if you've got
more suggestions too before you leave
don't forget to drop a like and check
out the channel for more amazing content
be sure to drop by my social media as
well you can support the channel through
patreon or come join the community at
discord i hope you enjoyed the video and
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you